TAS
DNESDAY, JUL
F ACCINE
PROPANN POLI ON TV
ATG AND COSTINIC5
LAY  DELTA V
ESW S UP HIGHER THAN LT EKOFFICT
POPULATION D THE
RISE OF TH TRANSMISSIBVARIANT,9.
HAN 99%,
EMERGENCY ROTOR TOLD UCOVID PATR
ALL  SOME, THIS IST A
SHOW.
A LYT MAKES YOU THINK ONCEINK A
IT'S BEET CO DAYE IT'S ABOUT SO.
>> IEA -- I DON'T --
THS  I HONESTLY
THINK ITHE MY LIFE TIME BY FTHOH
99E
>> OBVIOUS'M A DOCTOR,BUI'T RE
VACC AUT NATURE ORD I FEEL LIKE
A WEIRD WAY IS JUSGENERALLY
KIND OF GOIN.RE'S ST  MAYBE TREB
AM OHAGOES WSUPPOSED T CERTAIN
VACCESND IN THE
>>71 HAVE EDOF99T IN
>>O E ITOEK AND
THEY'RMP T?
TE TO THINK THAT
ESPECIALLY IF YOOT
SHOTS.
BUWHHE OTHER
EXPLANATION?LE CASES
ADS SENDING HE PANC. UNDERSCE N
PEOPLE TITIES  EDUCATESI
BEPTICAL OF THE VACCINE,
THT SHOWIN TO FO
NEEDLES.
T TOR PRESSURE
IS GREATMISSOURI'S GOVERNOR LIP
S TO TAKE THEIR
VACCINE  JALN ELSEWH OM
H YOUR FAUCI OUCHIE.
YOU LEAVE US THE HELALON NOW TAB
THINK ABOUAT T OO BE ABLE TO PEO
MECHANISMS BEDR  Y
GUNS AND BIBLES.
>> THEY'RE GOC DOOR.
THEY'RE GOING TOEMAND THAT YOU
TAKEING TO GIVE YOU IRHEN IT CO
PRIVAC T THE
CH IS A REALOBNISTRA ON VACCINAS
MIND BOGGL
>>, 607,771 F E VIRUS AND % OF E
PEOPLE DYING RIGHT NOW AREUNVAC.
>> WE'NG WE HAVE
M
NOT GOINIVE IN A
MEDICAL APARTHEID BECAUSE TH
DOE VACCINE.
THIS IS BI'S
ALMOHIS YLE OPEN
YOVE YOUFREEDOM YOU GE
>> IT IS J BEING WP DOORK, T,
THE ECONOMY, QUITETO
KEEP BREATHING. OVERALL, E EQUAY
R VACCINATION OF
ANELOW AGE 30. WE REALLY HAVE
>> AND THEN IN, THTH.
D  SCRAPPING ALL OH R ANY VACCI.
, FOR ALL .
>> INOE
ON T VERGE AGAINST ALL SCIENCE
OF MANDANG VACCINES FOR
THATE'N THE VERGAST
ATTENDANTS OUT THERE THERE  FLIT
ARE SOME FLIGHT ATANTAKE THEIR
POLICEO
>> THAT IS TRUE.
>>
>> MLIOFCANS ARES NONSENSICAL, -
[ LABORE07CANS HAVED
OF THE.
99% OF THEING RIGHUNIN C
COUNTRIES THAT DON'T HAVE ACCES.
MANY OF THE AMERICANS WHO DIED
YNOT HAVE DIEAC CURRENTLYAVAIL.
607,771 AMERSOME, MANY, MAYBEVEE
VACCINE HAD BEEN THERE I
FOR THEM.
BY SIMPLET OR, YOU'LLAMERICANSWE
THESE TV T
HAVEUS
ABOUT THCA
BEPONSE TO
CORONAVIRUS PAEMW LA OY MIFOGHW
NO.AKES.
JOINING US NOW FORE IS BN MEDI,
FOT BECAUSE OF T NH.
TELL US AB.
TELL US WH IT'S OBVIOUSLY PRETTY
O
ORGANIZATION TO TELLNE
THT TOLERATE WHAT
THEIR ORGANIZATION IG.
BUT YOU JUST CITED THE FIGURESA
THIS?AN, L
HEIR REASON FOR SAYING
OH, BE SKEPT
VACCE?TING.
VACCINATED, AT LEASTOU'RE
DOING YOUR JOB.
YO IO NOTE HONEST
INFORMATN  LIVES, I  DON'T UNDEO
CAN JUY
IF YOU'RE A PROFESSIONAL IN THE
THIS SINFORALE T COULD COST
, I DON'KNOWU CAN FUNCTIA
NAWAST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
'RTH TAKEN T
DA
HINK FOXOS
WH REAL YO?HIS IS THE OI
COME UWITH ICA
VIEW FHEINOR THENT O
THAT YOU CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
BECAE K
AS IWORKED BRILLIANTLY FOR HAVEN
IT MIG HBIDEN.
IT MIGHT HELP HIS
ADMINISTTION.
AND YOU CAN'T HAVE T
, WE'RGO  GOIN
GIVE PEOPLFOAT ND UP KILLING .ME
WHERE SOME PEOPLE WERE POISONGO.
THEYE  UP AND
SAYING, 99 PEOPL
GETTINRE TEN'T VACCINATED.
AND YOU CAN BENG THOSE WHOSAFE
TRUMP HAD WOONN OFFICE, THEY WO
AND  KNOW THAT.E.